so you're a country like china or russia
you obviously view america as the evil
enemy and your goal is to crush them to
become the next world superpower
back in the good old days you would
simply invade them and then kill their
leaders once you eliminated their
leaders you were afraid to pillage their
resources do stuff to their women that
we can't talk about without getting
demonetized then you would turn their
population into your servants and then
boom life would be good the problem is
today things are a little different for
one america's military would simply
crush you they spend the most they have
the most combat experience in the world
many people in america have guns they
have the latest and greatest weapons
fifth generation fighter jets the list
goes on so finding them head on would be
foolish on top of that today we have to
consider things like optics although
we're still the exact same savage humans
we were a thousand years ago today
things have to look just fair civil just
look at how russia invaded ukraine
optically putin looks like an evil bully
picking on a defenseless country so the
public rallies behind ukraine they cheer
on sanctions they cheer on the seizure
of yachts belonging to russian oligarchs
and so on this is not what we want
but what if i told you there was a much
subtler much more pernicious form of
warfare that allows us to achieve the
same goal remember we want to take out
the leaders of the empire you're looking
to destroy we can achieve that same goal
without outright invading them without
nasty public assassinations without
throwing the first punch without looking
like the bad guy
enter microwave weapons okay now hear me
out i know this sounds ridiculous i know
this sounds like sci-fi fantasyland but
just give me a chance here
if we had some sort of energy weapon
that was able to direct an energy blast
that can't be seen by the naked eye i'd
say a cia spy that would give that caa
spy a traumatic brain injury he wouldn't
be able to work anymore he would be out
of service he wouldn't be able to spy on
you anymore you would be able to achieve
the same effect that you would get from
killing a senior cia officer but without
escalating tensions without the
retaliation without the overt act of war
without ever leaving a trace
why because gunshot wounds knife moves
even poisonings they're all obvious you
can obviously tell if someone got shot
you can test to see if someone was
poisoned but what was that you randomly
get painful headaches now so you can't
go to work anymore stop being baby
what's wrong with you
it is invisible
if such an energy weapon like this
existed it would be a terrifying game
changer but lucky for you it looks like
it just might
this is mark polymeropolis an xcia agent
with over 26 years of service under his
belt with many of those years spent
chasing down terrorists in 2015 he was
promoted to the head of operations for
the cia in europe and eurasia so he was
a very vital guide to the cia to say the
least which also meant he posed a real
threat to powers like russia and china
and as a part of that position as head
of operations for europe and eurasia he
was responsible for overseeing the cia's
operations in russia the only problem
was he knew nothing about russia
i was not a russia expert i'd never been
there so i did what you know even going
back to our first part of our
conversation you know you need some area
fam so i was like i gotta take a trip to
moscow
so to prep for his new role mark took
his short trip to moscow in 2017 to get
a lay of the land and that's when it
happened you know i'm at the uh at the
uh at a five-star hotel about two blocks
from the u.s embassy again a routine
trip
didn't expect anything it was it was i
mean wearing a business suit um
something i had to do to kind of i
thought for my credibility as a senior
operations manager at our headquarters
overseeing russia i got to go visit
russia
but i woke up in the middle of the night
with a with and i didn't hear anything
but it was the stunning case of vertigo
um the room is spinning um i had
terrible tinnitus which is you know
ringing in my ears probably you're a
familiarity with that from kind of
exposures to blasts and and and but it
was tinnitus um i was splitting headache
and i was i was you know felt physically
sick but it was the just this incredible
case of vertigo which was
frankly terrifying and again i told you
about all the kind of the crazy moments
in my life before my career um something
really had happened
uh by the next morning um
i went you know to a far pharmacy with
the us embassy officer um it was some
kind of medication to kind of control
the vertigo it got a little bit better
went to st petersburg for the night came
back and then i got i suffered another
spell i remembered a moscow restaurant
and almost passed out but the room's
spinning and then i spent the next 36
hours of my hotel room before i kind of
crawled home
but something awful happened to me and
i was with a colleague as well
someone who worked for me traveling from
headquarters um
he was hit by this as well he has lost
uh hearing in one of his ears
um and uh and so something awful
happened that time i get back to our
headquarters immediately you know and
and my condition is actually getting
worse i go to our medical staff
and i said hey something really bad
happened in in uh in moscow i you know
i've heard of things like this
um in uh uh
to our folks in havana can you just
check me out and they kind of ran
through some havana the protocols that
they developed for for officers who had
been hit by this this
you know uh unknown ailment in nevada
but they said they didn't seem that that
i kind of qualify for whatever i didn't
hear anything they were very focused
that i didn't actually hear anything but
my condition was getting worse and again
this was i was i was in the senior
intelligence service i was the deputy
and i became the acting chief of
european eurasia this is a this is a job
which is you know a huge stepping stone
um to the really most senior ranks but i
couldn't even go to work i mean i was
having debilitating headaches every day
um i at one point by march of 2018 i
lost the ability uh for long distance
vision i couldn't drive
um
i had suffered terrible cognitive
difficulties with brain fog and i was i
was
i went to every doctor under the sun
whether it's neurologists infectious
disease doctors
allergists um uh i think i had about six
or seven mris no one could figure out
what was going on but i was really
suffering and at that point i was going
to work two or three hours a day
um but it just wasn't getting any better
um and i i was i was going through our
operations directorate pleading for them
to actually send me
to the university of pennsylvania where
they had sent some of the havana victims
and our office of medical services kept
rejecting me and it just
you know it's really this is this is a
really terrible tale of incompetence a
senior cia officer managing around 2 000
other cia personnel under his belt was
eliminated as a threat the equivalent of
killing him he had to retire all without
a bullet ever being fired all without
any of his higher ups even believing
that he was attacked
and that is what we call the art of war
but mark isn't the only one in 2016
nearly 20 american personnel stationed
in havana cuba all reported the same
experience they woke up in the middle of
the nights to a loud piercing sound in
one ear followed by intense nausea and
vertigo it felt like the world was
spinning around them they couldn't keep
their balance their head started
pounding unbearably some would struggle
to see clearly some were taken out of
service but there was no apparent
evidence that they were attacked all
they knew was that something was very
very wrong
and then it spread it spread to american
officials in china vietnam london and
even some officials working in the white
house
dozens of reports turned into hundreds
of cases hundreds of cases turned into
more than a thousand cases to this day
and the only victims so far have been
american diplomats government officials
or their family members with around half
of the victims being exclusively cia
personnel including a handful of
canadian officials as well
it was such a mystery that a new term
was coined for it havana syndrome but
you and i both know what it probably is
this is probably a targeted attack an
act of war by what a u.s intelligence
panel have guessed as some sort of
directed energy and there are only three
countries in the world that have gone on
record to say that they've dabbled with
microwave or energy weapons the us
china and russia my name is jake tran
and we make documentaries on money power
war and crime so that you can see the
world for what it really is a giant game
of acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player your parents teachers friends
society will never teach you any of this
so we're going to
stay dangerous and this is the havana
syndrome
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the xcia agent we just talked about has
recently released a book called clarity
in crisis unlike most books written by
ex spies or soldiers this isn't just
another autobiography filled with a
bunch of stories from his glory days it
is a deep dive into the most valuable
strategies mark used to deal with 26
years with some of the most
high-stressed situations anyone could
ever experience and the best part is
that you can listen to the audiobook
right now for free by signing up for
audible with the link below audible is a
super easy sell for me because i've been
using them for over 4 years now and the
stuff i've learned from their audiobooks
has completely changed my life for the
better and i cannot thank them enough i
would literally be using audible to the
day i die because listening to
audiobooks is way easier than reading
and you can do it anywhere i listen when
i'm driving working out and doing chores
audible is the biggest audiobook
platform in the world that is constantly
getting bigger and it has audiobooks on
anything you could possibly be
interested in once you sign up you can
choose one title per month to keep from
their entire catalog and that includes
new releases and bestsellers you'll also
have access to exclusive audible
originals from mclean experts and top
celebrities and you can try it out
before fully committing because new
members get 30 days of audible for free
so pause the video and get 30 days of
audible for free by going to audible.com
or texting jake tran to 500 500 again
that's audible.comtrain with the link
below or text jake trent to 500-500
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
it was rough in the beginning it was a
dark place to be we were kind of shoved
aside and they wanted it to go away all
the dogs started kicking off in the
neighborhood barking which is very
unusual for them all to go and chorus
and then this just loud sound just
absolutely filled my room it felt like
my head was slowly starting to get
crushed and then severe ear pain started
so i liken it too if you put a q-tip too
far and you bounce off your eardrum well
imagine taking a sharp pencil and just
kind of poking that it was very
jarring and painful
and eventually i started blacking out
his brain injuries left him disabled
essentially retired at the age of 36.
a weighted vest helps him balance
his service dog helps with walking
and his loss of vision the man in this
clip was one of the first people to
experience havana syndrome in cuba that
first year the american government had
no clue what was happening to its
employees people were getting deathly
ill suffering life-changing disabilities
and no one could figure out why
somewhere something was very very wrong
had the cubans been poisoning u.s
embassy staff were they secretly trying
to kill high-level american diplomats
things got so bad that the embassy in
havana was almost shut down because so
many people were being withdrawn back to
america it was an unexplainable
phenomenon but one thing was sure the
cubans were to blame but then havana
syndrome started to spread and that
threw the cuba theory out of the window
over the next two years americans in
europe china and russia started
experiencing the exact same symptoms
not even white house employees in
america were safe
this is olivia troy an
ex-counter-terrorism and homeland
security advisor to vice president mike
pence
the first time she experienced havana
syndrome she was walking down a set of
stairs near the west wing of the white
house but it was like this piercing
feeling on the side of my head it was
like i remember it was on the right side
of my head and i i got like vertigo um i
was unsteady
um i was
i felt nauseous
i was somewhat disoriented and i was
just i remember thinking like okay you
gotta you don't fall down the stairs
like you've gotta find your ground again
and steady yourself it was almost like i
couldn't really process it was like a
paralyzing panic attack i've never had
that um i've never felt anything like
that and so i you know i thought to
myself i mean do i have a brain tumor
out of the blue is this what happened am
i having a stroke and she wasn't the
only one
in 2020 another white house official
experienced the exact same symptoms on
those same stairs
whatever havana syndrome was it was now
on american soil and the more people who
got it the more it started seeming like
havana syndrome wasn't just a
coincidence or a random illness instead
it was beginning to look like a set of
extremely dangerous targeted attacks
by 2018 the american government had a
serious threat on its hands and if they
were going to fight havana syndrome they
were going to have to do some
investigating
as soon as havana syndrome started
spreading away from cuba the cuban
government was basically exonerated from
all wrongdoing if the culprit was ever
going to be found investigators would
have to start thinking out of the box
so they tested for everything from
pesticides to mental illness and still
came up with nothing they were just
about to give up when the first viable
theory finally hit them
microwaves
microwaves are used in lots of different
things from cell phones to radios and
even radar but exposure to microwave
radiation could also cause all the same
symptoms as havana syndrome the weird
sound everyone heard just as they
started experiencing the other symptoms
could be explained by something called
microwave hearing or the fray effect
the fray effect occurs when microwaves
cause you to hear sounds like ringing
loud noises and even human voices
exactly what happens to almost everyone
when they're hit with havana syndrome
other symptoms of microwave exposure
include headaches neurological problems
sleep issues memory loss and dizziness
with this new theory in mind researchers
took another look at the brain scans of
the people affected by havana syndrome
this time around they noticed small
details in most of the brain scans that
matched what they would expect from
someone affected by what do you know
microwave exposure
microwave exposure that could be created
by a machine small enough to fit in a
van but there are still unanswered
questions if it was a weapon how could
it be so directed as to hit only one
person in a building full of people how
could it be that targeted
and who would have such a weapon
[Music]
[Music]
there's only three countries on record
that have
kind of dabbled in microwave weapons yep
u.s china russia russia it was 1996
just five years after the fall of the
soviet union
two nsa agents were sent to a hostile
country on a short assignment a few days
into their trip one of the agents woke
up in the middle of the night feeling
deathly ill he couldn't move he felt
weak and his whole body seemed to be
overcome by fatigue in his own words it
felt like he had become quote a bowl of
jelly end quote
eventually the symptoms went away but
the agent never forgot that strange
night
ten years later that same agent was
diagnosed with early onset parkinson's
disease at just 46 years old he had
developed a brain disorder that left him
without control of his body's movements
balance or coordination
around the same time his colleague who
was also on the same mission was
diagnosed with parkinson's disease too
both men believed their assignment in
1996 had caused their illness
and when one of them reported it to the
nsa they received a strange reply quote
the national security agency confirms
that there is intelligence information
from 2012 associating the hostile
country to which mr beck traveled in the
late 1990s with a high-powered microwave
system weapon that may have the ability
to weaken intimidate or kill an enemy
over time and without leaving evidence
end quote here was the nsa confirming
that there was intel that some country
had a high-powered microwave weapon all
the way back in the late 90s but no
matter how much the media pushed no one
would say which country mr beck and the
other agent had visited
luckily they didn't need to
that's because going back as far as 1953
the american government had known about
russia's interest in using microwaves to
disrupt american embassy staff and
interfere with their communications
between 1953-1900
[Music]
over 20 years a microwave signal was
aimed at the american embassy in moscow
from an apartment building around 100
yards away
for years the american government had
tried to keep it a secret but when the
ambassador suddenly became sick and
started bleeding from his eyes the
government had to share the information
with its employees
so not only had the russians used
microwaves once before to target the us
embassy but there was a good chance that
the hostile territory the two nsa agents
visited in 1996 was either russia or an
ex-soviet country too
it was starting to look a lot like
russia was a viable suspect
and then mark polymeropolis the ex-cia
officer we mentioned earlier visited
moscow in 2017 and that basically sealed
the deal
mark was getting the exact same response
from the american government as the u.s
embassy staff in moscow had more than 50
years earlier complete denial
according to them he wasn't experiencing
havana syndrome it was something else
something the cia was definitely not
responsible for and it wasn't just him
apparently the cia had been denying
treatment and tests to loads of other
employees experiencing the same thing
it got so bad doctors were warning the
cia that if they kept delaying treatment
for these officers they were going to
have to deal with catastrophic
consequences
that's how terrified and helpless havana
syndrome made these decorated cia
officers feel
people who were used to dealing with
some of the most high stress high
pressure situations imaginable were on
the brink of suicide but no matter how
much mark pushed for his condition to be
recognized as havana syndrome and for
him to get access to treatment the cia
just wouldn't give in
for the american government admitting
that there might be a powerful invisible
weapon being used against american
personnel that they don't know about and
the fact that the cia was neglecting
treatment for their employees that were
affected wouldn't look good so to the
public the government downplays it
they explain it away
in a recent report out of the one
thousand cases of havana syndrome the
cia reported that
976 were related to environmental causes
or underlying medical issues
because obviously nearly 1 000 people
having the exact same symptoms in a six
year period is just a coincidence
nothing more
no need to panic here but hidden in the
details were a few cases that they
concluded were most likely from directed
energy
but behind closed doors it's a different
story just two years earlier the
department of defense put out a contract
for a wearable radio frequency weapon
exposure detector a wearable sensor to
detect if you've been hit by a radio
frequency weapon that doesn't happen if
people in the government don't think
this is real
you know we know the russians have this
uh it it is it is an open source
information the russians have dabbled in
this in this technology and in these
weapons and they've admitted it um if
they're able to take you know some of
our most experienced officers uh you
know uh off the battlefield um in a
non-attributable way it's perfect um
it's been successful because not only
has it really
uh uh taken um you know really quality
intelligence officers uh you know out of
the intelligence game it's also caused
this huge kind of dissension i mean
think of so so when you say havana
syndrome some people roll their eyes
some people don't believe this um it's
it's this is exactly what the russians
want yeah um it's the kind of cause
chaos um so it's so in my view it's been
wildly successful even though things
seem quieter now today it looks like
havana syndrome is here to stay for the
foreseeable future
every couple of days more u.s officials
and cia officers come forward with the
same symptoms the biden administration
is even offering some victims between
100 000 and two hundred thousand dollars
in compensation for their suffering
so no matter how badly the cia wants to
downplay havana syndrome it's not going
away anytime soon
[Music]
the russian government and intelligence
services have a long history of testing
weird weapons and spy gadgets on
unsuspecting americans but they're not
the only ones for years the cia tested a
huge range of drugs and psychological
torture on its own officers and even
innocent american citizens as part of
their mk ultra program
a program that the cia hoped would give
them the power of mind control
they thought if they pumped people full
of chemicals and exposed them to enough
shock fear or pain they would eventually
become brainless puppets
puppets the cia could use as
cold-blooded assassins that would do
anything they asked without a moment's
hesitation mk ultra was one of the
darkest cia programs in history but
going into how it started what they did
and how mk ultra probably gave us some
of america's most famous criminals like
whitey bulger and the unabomber means
taking a deep dive into all the evil
abusive methods they used and that would
get any public video on youtube
instantly demonetized
so instead we released it as a private
full-length documentary only available
to members of this channel
all you have to do to watch our full
documentary on mkultra is to hit that
join button below
once you do you'll also have access to
all our other videos on topics like the
cia's network of black sites and the
enhanced interrogation techniques used
there then we have one on everyone's
favorite private island owner every
gepstein and so much more
people spend years of their life and
tens of thousands of dollars to attend
university only to leave not knowing
anything about how the world really
works
but by becoming a member you'll get
access to all this insider info for only
five dollars a month
and trust us it's way more entertaining
than university lectures
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most youtube memberships
so if you join and you don't think it's
worth it email us within your first
month of joining for the first time and
we will personally refund you for your
first month
after your first month there is no
refund
after i saw sean ryan's interview about
the havana syndrome i knew i had to make
a video on it and if you haven't heard
sean rodney he has these really good
interviews integrating ex-military
people like special forces soldiers you
hear a lot of cool world-related stories
that you don't hear anywhere else you
should definitely check it out i'll link
it below and if you're new to this
channel this is one of the biggest
channels on youtube for documentaries on
money power war and crime so if you
enjoyed this video we have many more
like these coming out so click the
subscribe button below but that is going
to wrap it up stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next
[Music]
you